this is a production of Cornell
University so basically just this Jenna
mentioned this is about working progress
however I've had the chance to work with
it for a little bit so I hope to show
some progress over what I showed last
year which are the same thing here is a
particular issue of my having to define
what I already don't show what I have to
do but I hope I don't do such a bad so
first it's like okay so I'm going to
talk about a little bit about what the
project actually is so there's what I
want to achieve with it and what this
whole save actually I'm looking forward
to again I'm how I'm gonna try and do
that so those background all these these
project these things to see MIT data
basically they have these germplasm
collections part of the C sub Discovery
Project which includes about 4,700
Maslin races from all over Latin America
and the particularity of these land
races is that well they've been selected
over by multiple generations where the
breathers and these locations have been
able to like keep em in location so
these land races have been genotyped
through GPS markers which gave us us
about like 300,000 actually imputed
markers and the interesting bit of these
land races is that about 3,000 of them
have a geographical information data
from where they were collected these
data includes
these variables right here which is
basically environmental information that
in theory has actually held some
pressure on the way the breeders have
been selecting the specific Cesar they
keep for each successive generation to
keep growing on their on their plots so
for example we can think of
precipitation this is just a map showing
where of these lot of races have been
collected from and it is showing the
[Music]
normalized values for the precipitation
variables specifically there has been
average for the six month growing period
so we can see that depending on these
land races have been growing they have a
tendency to have lower or higher levels
of precipitation considering the maze
it's a now crossing species you can
actually like just cross within the
fields and then the farm
it selects whatever is growing better
and then keeps the seed and grows it
again successively over like however
many years because this collection has
actually been intimate all the way from
like 1950 so it's actually what we want
to do with this specific data that we
have is sort of like the typical
Association studies to hopefully
identify alleles that are kind of like
related hopefully related to the
individual variables that we will be
studying so normally we think phenotype
and genotype we do an association study
like G was reading a my prediction and
that give us in theory alleles that have
actually been associated to control
these variable however as we might know
as well generally we don't have a fully
imputed I fooled a sequence genome for
all of these land races or whatever
occasions we might be working so they
have to go through a process of
imputation which is like don't thanks to
like having some form of shallow
sequencing or in our case GPS markers so
these imputation process has some issues
a little bit and as well the Association
studies are compounded by problems such
as population structure and the genetic
architecture of the trait these causes
issues where like you might find
identification of association with
alleles that have nothing to do with the
trade just on the way that which
population has been kept and growing so
we have to control for that and finally
those beneficial alleles that we are
very identifying I've also also have to
be validated because well use the fact
that we find it associated actually also
for them so my objective of the project
is kind of like attack all these three
individual points to hopefully like just
and leverage with information that we
have on these learn races I have
naturally been selected to perform under
these conditions so thus far what have I
done
so the imputation kind of works that
means that we have a GU sort of
correlation which is like a point six
seven which is not great however is
useful however as we can see in this
plot the imputation tends to fail over
mostly on the minor allele frequencies
which tends to be the one
and to have like a higher effect on the
individual trades that we might have an
interest on so we have to improve that
this isn't trivial because so far has
been this the best one has worked for
our specific material because that's
also one of the problem with the
imputation it's totally dependent on the
population are you working with the same
sense doing some Association studies
just G was particularly trying to
explain the environmental variables we
have to include some kind of a variable
that's going to control for the
population structure because otherwise
what we tend to find issues basically
these Manhattan Plaza we have like
incredibly significant sites all over
the genome bar is right here so we have
almost all of the thing being
significant but that's just because well
the genome has been selected for the
population structure in itself so that's
not great so what do we do we try
different models for example a mixed
leaner model in which we includes pcs
and geographical covariance which is
lighter that a longitude and what
happens we basically lose all signal
however though the most significant
sites still tend to be the same but
they're not significant anymore so what
do we have to do we have to basically
what find a way to basically increase
the signal after you control for
population structure so how do we do
that so the first step is basically well
what happens if we just make a better
imputation so we have better initially
data so for that purpose the lab about
their life we're working on they're
trying to develop these practical
helpful state graph which is basically
trying to use data from sequence
assembly sequence genomes from base a
diverse set of them or just a simple
high def sequencing where basically
they're trying to process the different
assemblies identifying k-mers over what
are the specific we're calling the
reference intervals which are in general
just genic regions because those are the
ones that are simpler to impute they
include the promoter sequences another
mostly informative
pieces of a genome but at the same thing
we're keeping the rest of it as well
however this is where we're calling
these a blue tights and this generates a
database of hopefully good curated
haplotype structures based on the
population that the database was
actually generated from so having those
sequences that we'd already have there's
like 20 some assemblies as it is right
now what we want or what I would like to
do is basically use these GPS data or if
we need some more data pass it to the
database you basically impute these
landraces
into these other sequences sequence
genomes that are better assembled so
hopefully that would give us the
possibility to identify associations
more more likely or with better with
higher power
why because well instead of if we were
trying to identify association between
snips we can't have my hundreds of
thousands of incident millions which
basically produces the ability to
identify Association because you have so
many things this for if instead of
testing for hundreds of thousands of
them were just identifying several tens
of thousands which are just the guinea
regions we might get a bump on that the
same in the same way by we have also
these land races already sequenced some
of them so they may also give us ability
to test this imputation approach to see
if it's actually working but again this
might require more so so that we'll see
what happens with that and a theory is a
PhD if I could have a graph is being
developed so it's going to be part of
the project itself the other thing is to
the association approach so once we have
these imputed genotypes there's these
approaches that are using summary
statistics from G was where we're
actually just using the end results for
them and what it actually does instead
of using the genetic structure of the
individual
phrase that we're looking for do you
like find an association and the
basically the fact that the the
population structure and it's only sort
of shared so that you're hoping to share
alleles in there and also the genetic
architecture for the visual trace my
sure as well
this in a specific protocol MTAC looks
actually to identify a bump on the
association by just mixing that up and
at the same times if we wanted to
develop these data to be stored on on a
data base keeping the individual data is
kind of there's a lot of information so
if you seen somebody sitting see might
actually allow us to keep the data
accessible for more people another step
sorry is to actually instead of using
just the individual genotypes that we're
doing is to try and do the Association
by potentially allowing the I'm sorry
I'm losing my voice the alleles that are
on there higher frequency we could
potentially impute the individual
alleles between the thurman lower
frequency which kind of the genotype
bias by a shallower sequencing approach
but of course is completely dependent on
the fact that we might not get good a
haplotype thing but again this is stuff
that needs to be tested and finally all
of these Association studies through the
mental variables how can we test that
well we have some information for
flowering time trials for these land
races that have been grown on all these
different regions across Mexico that
have been selected in to be like sort of
performing well under the visual
environments that they are there so I
try some individual a genome-wide
prediction models and we can see that
both using the environment as a
predictor for the flowering time data is
giving us some kind of signal which is
telling us that the variables are
related to the way that these land races
come performing they're by themselves
however of course using the normal
genotype approaches predictors for these
flowering time data we have a sort of
like relatively good prediction of 0.5 a
relation between base two and thesis
over these multiple trials so what we
would like to see is basically if we
select different genotypes or these
regions for the genome we should be able
to see an improvement over this
prediction or at least that's what it
will like
sport and I'm gonna just skip on this
sorry about that
so I want to thank the people at SEMA
for really data and the support and
definitely the butter lab because all of
these is thanks to them and the research
and everyone is doing it we're sharing
and going to see for my scholarship do
one more here as well you guys have
questions any questions for you I'm
curious about your environmental data
are you looking at like an average over
a certain historical time period or as
singles rather variation right so we
have the variability visually for each
of them the months of the year but there
was this stuff that I've been working
with this you know ever has been average
over the six month growing period for
the field season so I could definitely
test individual months to see how they
do
thus far the six month early period has
seemed to be working yes yeah so this is
all data that's kind of like average for
the location in which each of these
spaces have been growing and that's sort
of like the number let's understand that
to be occurring in that location yeah
you have you looked at prediction
jamming prediction or maybe associations
looking only at the genes at the genic
regions given that you're going to be
later relying on imputation only around
the gene regions no I have not and
that's basically what I still wanted so
what I've done is use genomic prediction
across the whole genome and I was the
basically what I'm interested in is sort
of furthering down to just these genic
regions and then hopefully the
prioritization that I can get from the
g1 studies it makes that sort of like
increase hopefully increase prediction
accuracy but I have not tested just on
the genes
however since I have like GPS data you
might already be sort of biased towards
that but after computing I'm not sure
yeah all right well let's
Arkady another on this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at Cornell edu